let's look at the sun
without ruining our eyes of course
we'll use a filter that cuts out
99.999 percent of the light
what we see is a luminous nearly
featureless limb darkened disc
it doesn't give us many clues about what
the sun is
images at other wavelengths that
emphasize the high energy phenomena can
be much more dramatic
we can see glowing hot material welling
up through what looked like cracks in
the photosphere
flares blast away from the surface
like a sorcerer flinging fireballs
while we're admiring these images
let's ponder a number
3.8 times 10 to the 26
that's the sun's luminosity in watts
in this lecture
we're going to perform some calculations
to try and understand that number
you might want to get out your
calculator so you can follow along
3.8 times 10 to the 26 watts is a clue
about what's happening inside the sun
it is a lot of power
the earth intercepts less than a
billionth of the sun's total luminosity
and yet
even that tiny fraction
amounts to ten 000 times more power than
all the world's power plants put
together
and what's more the sun has been shining
a long time
4.6 billion years based on evidence from
primitive meteorites
geologists have found evidence that
liquid water oceans have also existed
for billions of years
so the sun's luminosity couldn't have
been much lower in the past or else
those oceans would have frozen
with these numbers we can calculate the
sun's total energy output since it
formed
we multiply the sun's luminosity by its
age
giving 5 and a half times 10 to the 43
joules of energy
where did all of that energy come from
maybe the sun is burning a fuel the way
a lantern burns kerosene
let's see how much kerosene would be
required
the combustion of one kilogram of
kerosene releases 46 million joules
megajoules of heat
the required mass of kerosene is
therefore five and a half times 10 to
the 43 joules
divided by 46 mega joules per kilogram
that gives 1.2 times 10 to the 36
kilograms
but today the sun's mass is only two
times ten to the thirty kilograms
so it's five hundred thousand times too
small
even if the sun were made of pure
burning kerosene it could shine for only
nine thousand more years
okay
maybe it's some other chemical fuel with
a higher energy output per unit mass
but no that can't be either
chemical reactions involve electrons
changing orbits or getting traded
between nuclei
as we saw in lecture two the energy
scale for those transitions is always on
the order of one electron volt per
proton mass
it's the scale that's set by the
marriage of electromagnetism and quantum
theory
and it's equivalent to about 100
megajoules per kilogram
you'll never find a chemical fuel that's
orders of magnitude better than that
so we need something else
early astrophysicists thought that that
something was gravity
the way a star forms is that a tenuous
cloud of gas contracts under its own
gravity into a smaller denser ball
but we shouldn't imagine this process as
a perfect sphere of gas whose radius is
getting smaller
the initial cloud was very patchy and
irregular
and so as it collapsed streams and
clumps of gas fell toward the center
crashing into each other producing
radiation and shock waves and a lot of
heat
the net effect was to convert
gravitational potential energy into
heat
to calculate how much heat
we start with the fact that the
gravitational potential energy of a
uniform sphere a ball of constant
density
is minus three-fifths gm squared over r
where m is the mass and r is the radius
the gm squared over r you could have
guessed from dimensional analysis it's
the only way to combine g m and r and
get the units of energy
and the three-fifths comes from doing
the problem exactly with calculus
now the sun is not a ball of uniform
density it's denser on the inside than
the outside
but we'll neglect that for this order of
magnitude calculation
and that initial cloud was so much
larger and more diffuse than the sun
that its energy was essentially zero by
comparison
so the energy released as heat was
three-fifths g m squared over r
and when you plug in the numbers for the
sun that comes out to 2.3 times 10 to
the 41 joules
that's still too small by a factor of
240.
if gravity had been the only power
source
the sun could only have sustained its
luminosity for 20 million years
not 4.6 billion
what we just did is a famous calculation
in the history of science
in 1862 lord kelvin used the same logic
to argue that the sun
and by extension the earth couldn't be
much older than 20 million years
that led him and others to doubt
darwin's new theory of evolution by
natural selection
darwin needed too much time for
creatures to evolve
what kelvin didn't know
was that within a few decades his
colleagues would start exploring the
atomic nucleus
as you probably already know
the answer to the riddle of the sun's
energy is nuclear
fusion nuclear reactions involve
rearrangements not of the electrons but
of nucleons protons and neutrons
the typical energies involved with those
rearrangements are millions of electron
volts that's the factor of a million
that we need beyond what chemistry can
deliver
that's what gives the sun its longevity
and what gave evolution enough time to
go from bacteria to bacteria and camels
and that's why we're going to need a
crash course in nuclear physics
first let's remember that an atomic
nucleus is a tiny bundle of protons and
neutrons at the center of a cloud of
electrons
in a neutral atom the number of protons
equals the number of electrons since
they have equal and opposite electric
charges
the number of neutrons is always about
the same as the number of protons or
somewhat higher for reasons we'll
discuss shortly
for example a carbon atom has six
electrons
around a nucleus of six protons and six
neutrons
some carbon nuclei though have seven
neutrons
we say carbon has two main isotopes
nuclei with the same number of protons
but different numbers of neutrons
you might wonder why do we call them
both carbon if their nuclei are
different why don't we just give each
nucleus a different name
it's because elements are named by
chemists not nuclear physicists
the chemical properties of an atom
depend almost entirely on the number of
electrons which is equal to the number
of protons
the neutron count doesn't matter so much
but it matters a lot for nuclear
reactions
when carbon is involved in a nuclear
reaction
we need to know which isotope we're
talking about
the convention is to specify the total
number of nucleons protons plus neutrons
which is often called the atomic mass
and represented by the letter a
for example
carbon-12 has six protons and six
neutrons
so a equals twelve
and we write it as a c with a 12 in the
upper left
another big difference between chemical
and nuclear reactions is the spatial
scale over which the changes occur
remember
if we expand a carbon atom to the size
of a football field most of that space
will be filled by the electron cloud
the nucleus would be less than a
centimeter across
the smaller scale of nuclei and the
million fold more energy that's released
are both consequences of the strength of
the strong nuclear force
and the short range over which it acts
compared to electromagnetism
let's be more quantitative
in chemistry a key concept is the heat
of formation the amount of energy
released if you make a molecule from its
elemental constituents
for example if you mix hydrogen and
oxygen to make water
you release 2.5 electron volts per water
molecule
that's the heat of formation of water
well the analogous concept in nuclear
physics is the nuclear binding energy
it's defined as the energy released if
you make a nucleus out of free protons
and neutrons
or equivalently it's the energy required
to completely disintegrate a nucleus
carbon-12 for example has a binding
energy
of 92 million electron volts
or mev
now it would be impossible to slam
together six protons and six neutrons
all at once to make carbon in reality
you would have to perform a sequence of
simpler steps involving only two nuclei
at a time
but it doesn't matter the difference in
binding energy between the starting and
ending nuclei doesn't depend on the path
you take to get from one to the other
the binding energies of all the most
stable isotopes have been measured in
laboratory experiments
let's look at a chart of the measured
binding energy b
versus the atomic mass a
the x-axis ranges from hydrogen at a
equals one to uranium at 238.
the data form an upward sloping nearly
straight line
that makes sense the bigger the nucleus
the harder we need to work to tear it
apart
the slope b over a tells us how hard
based on the chart it's about 2000 mev
divided by 250 or 8 mev per nucleon
but despite appearances
the line isn't exactly straight
let's get a clearer view instead of
plotting b
we'll plot b over a
versus a
now we see it's not as simple as 8 mev
per nucleon
small nuclei have a relatively low
binding energy per nucleon
b over a then rises to a maximum value
at an atomic mass of around 60.
the winner is nickel 62 followed closely
by iron 58 and iron 56 those are the
most stable nuclei
if you had a bunch of protons and
neutrons
and you gave them the opportunity to mix
and match however they want
they would tend to clump together into
nickel and iron that's how they achieve
the lowest possible energy
which might make you wonder
why isn't everything made of nickel and
iron
the answer is
nature doesn't provide nucleons with the
opportunity to mix and match however
they want nuclear reactions require high
densities and temperatures because
nuclei are all positively charged so
they repel each other
but when conditions do allow for
spontaneous nuclear reactions
they will tend to produce nuclei that
approach nickel and iron
smaller nuclei will tend to merge
together
that's fusion
larger nuclei are vulnerable to breaking
apart
which we call decay if only a little
piece of the nucleus breaks off
or fission if it breaks into chunks of
comparable size
in this sense the light nuclei like
hydrogen helium and carbon
want to fuse
and heavier elements like gold lead and
uranium
they wish they could break apart and
become more like nickel and iron
let's try to understand why the binding
energy curve has this shape
think back to our mental model of the
nucleus as a cluster of marbles
each one's coated with glue that's the
strong nuclear force
if a marble is surrounded by other
marbles
it takes about 8 mev of energy to
overcome all the glue and to pull it out
that's the average value of b over a
but that's not all there is to it
some of the marbles are near the surface
of the cluster so they're not surrounded
by marbles in all directions and they're
not glued as tightly in place
that lowers the binding energy relative
to the average
surface penalty is especially bad for
small nuclei
because they have the highest surface to
volume ratio
the surface area of a sphere grows as
radius
squared and the volume goes as radius
cubed
so the surface to volume ratio varies as
one over radius it gets worse for small
nuclei
another problem is that some of those
marbles the protons
repel each other
the electric repulsion works against the
glue lowering the binding energy
so there's a penalty for having protons
then why would a nucleus want to have
any protons why don't we see nuclei made
entirely from neutrons
it's because of another effect called
symmetry energy
roughly speaking the glue that sticks
nucleons together is a little stronger
when it's between a proton and a neutron
than it is between two protons or two
neutrons
that increases the binding energy of
nuclei with lots of proton neutron pairs
now we can understand the shape of the
binding energy curve
light nuclei suffer from high surface
area that's why their binding energy is
lower than average
very heavy nuclei also have low binding
energies because they suffer from an
internal conflict
as you keep adding nucleons to a nucleus
you'd like to avoid the proton penalty
and stick with neutrons
but to satisfy the desire for symmetry
you need to add some protons and the net
effect is to destabilize the nucleus
you may have also noticed there are some
spikes in the binding energy curve that
i haven't explained yet let's get a
better look at them by zooming in on the
lightest nuclei
these enhancements in binding energy
come from aspects of the strong force
that favor even numbers of protons and
even numbers of neutrons
helium-4 for example has two of each
so it's blessed with an especially high
binding energy
also in this category are beryllium-8
carbon-12 oxygen 16 and neon 20.
now let's return to the sun and the
problem of explaining its prodigious
energy we know from its spectrum that
the sun is mostly hydrogen
so could it be using hydrogen as a fuel
fusing it into helium
the stable nucleus of hydrogen h1
is just a proton with a binding energy
of zero
helium-4 has a binding energy of 7 mev
per nucleon
so hydrogen fusion releases 7 mev per
nucleon
that's equivalent to 670
million
megajoules per kilogram
that's 15 million times more than you
get from burning kerosene
but is it enough to explain the sun's
total energy output
let's calculate the required mass of
hydrogen
it's the sun's total energy output
divided by the energy per kilogram
released by fusion
giving 8.2 times 10 to the 28 kilograms
or equivalently
0.04 solar masses
by converting only four percent of its
hydrogen into helium
the sun can release enough energy to
shine for billions of years
speaking of mass
let's take this opportunity to talk
about the close relationship between
mass and energy
the one einstein taught us about e
equals m c squared
what this means is that
despite what we teach in freshman
physics
energy is not conserved and neither is
mass
interactions can change one into the
other
and the exchange rate is e equals m c
squared
mass and energy turn out to be the same
kind of stuff at a fundamental level
it's their combination that's conserved
an important implication is that when an
interaction releases energy
whether you're burning kerosene or
fusing hydrogen
the total mass of all the particles
involved must go down
the change in mass delta m is equal to
delta e over c squared
this happens during chemical reactions
but we never notice it the changes in
mass are only at the level of parts per
billion
but for nuclear reactions the changes
are more substantial
let's calculate the fractional change in
mass delta m over m
for hydrogen fusion
we'll take the 7 mev per nucleon that's
released during fusion
divide by c squared to get the
corresponding mass loss
and then divide by the mass of a proton
to make it into a fraction
the number comes out to be
0.0075
so if this is correct we should find
that a helium nucleus is less massive by
three quarters of a percent than the sum
of two isolated protons and two isolated
neutrons
which is true
the difference in mass can be measured
directly in laboratory experiments
all of this implies that the sun like
anything that radiates energy is losing
mass we can calculate how much
in time dt
the sun emits an energy d e and loses a
mass of d e over c squared
so the rate of mass loss
is d e dt over c squared where d dt is
the sun's luminosity
dividing the sun's luminosity by c
squared we get four times ten to the
nine kilograms per second
right
every second four billion kilograms of
mass are vanishing from the sun having
been converted into energy and flung out
into space
but don't be too concerned the sun is
not going to disappear any time soon
remember its total mass is 2 times 10 to
the 30 kilograms
even after 10 billion years
the sun will lose only about 0.07
percent of its mass in this way
now let's change gears
to this point in the lecture we focused
on calculating differences in energy or
mass
before and after some interaction
whether chemical gravitational or
nuclear
that led to some important insights
but the knowledge of energy differences
alone
doesn't tell us anything about the
mechanisms of the reactions
by what specific steps are the four
protons converted into helium
that's a much tougher question
in fact
even after it became clear that the
sun's luminosity has a nuclear origin
the sequence of reactions was the
subject of confusion and debate for
decades
we can't expect four protons to crash
into one another all at the same time
such four-body collisions are
vanishingly rare
the only plausible reactions are
two-body collisions
so
you would think the first step would be
to smash two protons together and make
helium two
but there are a couple of problems
the first problem is that protons repel
each other
how do we get them to approach each
other closely enough for the strong
force to take over
we can represent the problem
schematically by plotting the potential
energy of a proton as a function of its
distance from another proton
as we bring the protons together
the electric potential energy rises
it's eta times e squared over r where
eta is the coulomb constant and e is the
proton's charge
but
if they manage to get to within 1.5
femtometers that's 1.5 times 10 to the
minus 15 meters
then the strong force can take over and
the energy goes way down
the marbles have come close enough to
touch
and stick
to find the maximum height of the
potential energy barrier
we need to evaluate the electric
potential energy of two protons
separated by one and a half femtometers
that comes out to be one mev
so if we want the protons to stick
we need to throw one at the other with
at least one mev of kinetic energy
if it only has a quarter of an mev
the repulsion will cause it to slow down
halt at five and a half femtometers and
then fly away
so the question is
do the protons at the center of the sun
have at least one mev of kinetic energy
well
we have good reason to believe that the
temperature at the center of the sun is
15 million degrees kelvin
it's based on a calculation we'll
perform in the next lecture
and we know the average kinetic energy
per particle in a gas at temperature t
is three halves kt
multiplying three halves k
by 15 million kelvin gives .002
mev
now you see the problem
according to this calculation
the sun is way too cold
the protons should have no chance of
coming close enough to stick
so how do they even get started making
helium
the answer is amazing
you know what helps the protons
quantum theory
the time has come to set aside our
mental model of protons as marbles
like any fundamental particle
protons also have a wave-like nature and
are described by a wave function
a cloud of probability extending over a
region of
unlike classical particles
wave functions do not simply halt when
they reach a potential energy barrier
they can leak through
the amplitude of the wave function goes
down exponentially as it leaks through
so the portion that gets through the
barrier is tiny nevertheless
there's a chance for a proton to tunnel
through the barrier
even though officially it doesn't have
enough energy
this phenomenon is called quantum
tunneling and it's governed by the
schrodinger equation
we're not going to solve the schrodinger
equation but we will perform an order of
magnitude calculation to establish how
much energy a proton needs to have a
decent chance of tunneling through the
barrier
key concept
is the de broglie wavelength lambda d
defined as h over p
planck's constant over momentum
you can think of the de broglie
wavelength as the spatial extent of a
particle's cloud of probability
when you observe the particle it won't
necessarily be located where you would
expect based on classical physics
but you'll find it within about one de
broglie wavelength of that expected
location
what this means is that we don't need
the protons to get to within one and a
half femtometers of each other it's
enough that their wave functions overlap
to within about one de broglie
wavelength
and that turns out to be much easier it
doesn't require as much energy
let's see how that works
the de broglie wavelength is h over
momentum
but we're not interested in momentum
we're interested in kinetic energy
one-half mv squared
which is equal to p squared over 2m
and therefore p equals the square root
of 2 m e
so we can rewrite the de broglie
wavelength as h
over root 2 me
for the protons to approach within a de
broglie wavelength the required energy
is no longer a to e squared over one and
a half femtometers
it's a to e squared over lambda d
that leads to an equation with energy on
both sides which we can solve for energy
and then plug in the numbers
the answer is 0.0025
mev
that's three orders of magnitude lower
than one mev the required energy for
classical particles
and it's the same order of magnitude as
the average kinetic energy of protons at
the center of the sun
so it all hangs together
by relying on quantum tunneling
protons can fuse even at the low
temperature of 15 million kelvin
an important aspect of quantum tunneling
is the exponential falloff in the wave
function as it penetrates a barrier
because of that
the probability to tunnel through a
barrier depends very sensitively on
energy
small changes in energy lead to large
changes in the fusion rate
this fact will be crucial for our
understanding of stars
thermonuclear reaction rates where the
nuclei rely on random kinetic energy to
come together in fuse
depend very strongly on temperature
the rate of proton fusion in the sun
varies as temperature to the fourth
power
and some other important reactions vary
as t to the eighth power or even higher
powers
what this means in practice is that each
reaction has a sharply defined ignition
temperature
below which the power output is
negligible
and above which it's substantial
this will have important consequences
for stellar structure as we'll discuss
in the next lecture
for now let's be glad we've made
progress in understanding hydrogen
fusion
but we can't relax just yet there's
another problem helium-2 the nucleus
made from two protons
is extremely unstable so after all that
work bringing the protons together
the nucleus falls apart and we're back
to square one
this too was a historical puzzle with a
very subtle solution
in this case
what saves the day
is the weak nuclear interaction
the one that can convert protons into
neutrons and vice versa what happens is
the two protons approach each other and
right when their wave functions merge
there's a slight chance that one of them
will change into a neutron
spitting out a positron and a neutrino
in the process proton and the newborn
neutron make a nucleus of hydrogen 2
also known as deuterium which is stable
however the interaction that allows this
transformation is
well it's weak the probability is low
if you follow a single proton bouncing
around in the core of the sun
you have to wait several billion years
on average before you'll see it fuse
into deuterium
but after that things start happening
faster
within a few seconds
the deuterium smacks into another proton
and sticks
forming helium-3 and emitting a
gamma-ray photon
and from there
there are three different paths that
lead to helium-4
i'll just explain the simplest one
given enough time about 20 000 years
a helium-3 nucleus will find another one
and collide knocking away two protons
and what's left is two protons and two
neutrons
that's helium four the endpoint which is
very stable and interacts no further
at last we've achieved what we wanted we
identified the sun's energy source
thermonuclear fusion of hydrogen into
helium
and we learned the steps required to
fuse hydrogen into helium
let's close this lecture
one last calculation regarding the sun's
energy
we began by marveling at the sun's
luminosity 3.8 times 10 to the 26 watts
now i'd like to ask
what's the average power output per
cubic meter in the core of the sun
the core where the nuclear reactions are
taking place has a radius of about 70
000 kilometers about a tenth of the
sun's total radius
so let's take the sun's luminosity and
divide by the volume of the core
the answer in watts per cubic meter is
300.
does that surprise you
300 watts is not super impressive
my kitchen toaster emits a thousand
watts of heat
what we've just learned is that
we should not envision the sun as a
blast furnace with nuclear bombs going
off all the time far from it
it's much more like a collection of
toasters
spaced apart every few meters
what makes the sun so luminous
is that it's so big there are a lot of
toasters
and just as important the overlying
material the outer 90 of the sun is
optically thick
so it traps the energy for a long time
keeping the interior toasty hot
i just love thinking about the wide
range of physical processes going on
inside the sun
there's gravity to compress the interior
electromagnetism and the strong force
setting the energies of nuclear
reactions
the reliance of protons on quantum
tunneling and the weak nuclear
interaction to come together and undergo
reactions on time scales ranging from
seconds to billions of years
it all seems so utterly improbable
and yet it's all these processes working
together
that provide the energy for life here on
earth
[Music]
[Music]
you